I think about what it would have been
like to tell little baba Rami that uh
one day this might happen to him and I
think his curly hair little mind would
be blown that kid was uh he was
struggling with his identity I think to
anyone struggling with theirs and trying
to discover their voice listen we made a
film about a gay man an immigrant who
lived his life just unapologetically
himself
and the fact that I'm celebrating him
and this story with you tonight is is
proof that we're longing for for stories
like this I am the son of immigrants
from Egypt I'm a first generation
American and part of my story
is being written right now and I could
not be more grateful to each and every
one of you and and everyone who believed
in me is something I will treasure for
the rest of my life